liz cheney is counting on support from
democrats and cnn to help her win her
primary on august 16th her campaign sent
out this flyer to democrat voters in
wyoming which begins quote how do i
change my party affiliation to register
as a republican so i can vote for liz
this would have been unthinkable a
decade ago the democrat party have
aligned themselves now with liz cheney
and apparently dick cheney and what is
going on here exactly glenn greenwald is
an independent journalist his work is on
sub stack you can check it out and he
joins us now
glenn let's start with this idea first
of liz cheney as a presidential
candidate i can't i can't find a poll
glenn that shows she's going to win her
republican primary for congress why is
cnn floating a presidential campaign
you know it's bizarre will 2005 was when
i stopped working as a constitutional
lawyer in order to become a political
writer and a journalist and at the time
the absolute liberal consensus virtually
universal was that dick cheney wasn't
just someone who was misguided but was
somebody who was a fascist a racist a
bloodthirsty war criminal somebody who
had created a lawless presidency someone
who stole the 2000 election from
election from the rightful winner al
gore and liz cheney isn't just his
daughter she's somebody who has been
vocally defending her father's most
controversial policies from the
beginning and to this very day continues
to she's not somebody who recanted her
support for torture and domestic spying
in guantanamo and the war in iraq she's
somebody who continues to defend it and
so to watch liberals he prays on liz
cheney nancy pelosi called her a leader
of great courage integrity and honesty
is absolutely surreal but the the motive
is obvious which is literally anybody
who opposes donald trump becomes a hero
in the eyes of of democrats and liberals
you know you asked that question glenn
on twitter i saw it i wanted to bring it
up and i wanted to see if i could get
you to answer your own question um we
have the tweet which we can put up i
believe which you ask what is it
have liberals has the liberal mind
explored the explanation of why it would
be
that the man who they called a nazi
before calling people nazis was cool is
now one of the biggest opponents to
donald trump
why do you think liberals explain
cheney hating trump
yeah i think people have forgotten that
in 2016 the expectation of the
republican establishment was that the
almost certain winner the certain
nominee was going to be jeb bush and
donald trump campaigned vehemently
denouncing the entire bush cheney
foreign policy worldview not just the
war in iraq but the entire view that we
should always be at war that all of our
money should go to regime change all
over the world he denounced that
militaristic and imperialistic uh vision
as somebody that as something that
destroys peace in the world and benefits
only a tiny sliver of the american
population weapons manufacturers and the
like and donald trump won
and so what he basically did was expel
bush cheney ideology from the republican
party by denouncing them and all this is
the reason dick and liz cheney hate
donald trump or the bush family as well
is because it's just petty dynastic
vengeance they're angry that trump
positioned himself as an adversary and
opponent of their defining worldview and
ideology and legacy and he won the
republican primary by doing that so the
left so wedded to principle what at one
point the adversary of neoconservatism
aligns themselves today with the
originators of neo conservatism or the
banners of neoconservatism in order to
oppose donald trump because he was
opposed to neoconservatism
really really principled
glenn greenwald thank you so much for
joining us tonight subscribe to the fox
news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight